il est 8 heures le paris des touristes
s'éveille et la ronde quotidienne des
quarts commencent avec leur musique
assourdissante dérives des bruits de
moteur qui tout autant l'air que le
charme parisien derghal 400 cartons
chaque jour autour de la butte
montmartre
lassé de devoir rappeler à l'ordre
constamment les chauffeurs la mairie du
xviiie vient de renforcer la législation
sur le stationnement
il y avait une interdiction partielle
effectivement qui montre d'ailleurs que
les pouvoirs publics étaient préoccupés
déjà il ya quelques années de cette
question mais elle ne suffisait pas et
surtout n'étaient pas appliquées dans le
jargon du métier
on les appelle les quarts blanc toulouse
après avoir déposé les touristes
certains restent sur place tourne autour
des sites parisiens
rares sont ceux qui rejoignent le
boulevard de clichy plus pourtant le
stationnement est gratuit
il est 20 heures les touristes vont
dîner et la rue descartes portions pour
les grosses sociétés parisiennes du
transport de touristes
l'interdiction du car à ma marque est
une bonne nouvelle une façon de lutter
contre les 48 souvent étrangers il est
vrai que le fait de dates à dire un
petit peu à tous et 40 ou de stationner
au pied de la butte montmartre
c'est quelque chose qui est bien beau
pari pour l'image de paris donc on y est
favorable
il est vrai que ça en plus ça nous
touche pas directement puisque nous tous
nos cas stationnent au parking du louvre
donc on ne fait que sortir du parking
prendre nos clients et les emmener là où
il le souhaite c'est qu'il paye un
abonnement pour le parking et leurs
véhicules encombrants et pognon gêne un
peu mieux tous les autres qui dit
une province devront apprendre à en
faire autant à partir du mois de
novembre
l'accès à la butte montmartre leur sera
définitivement un terrain